[Musique]
tél lorsque j'ai été sollicité vous ce
thème et j'étais tout excité
edit ah enfin j'ai ressenti de maison
jean a peur et on me dit thème de cette
année c'est la percée la partie de
raconter mon parcours que j'ai j'ai
réalisé et je me suis dit est ce que mon
parcours était assez inspirante j'allais
venir vous rend compté de comment est ce
que en fait le site internet des
applications java palais des langages
informatiques html javascript it on
franchement je voulais pas vous infliger
cela
et pendant que je faisais mes recherches
par mois que je réfléchissais à la
thématique qui sont tombés par contre si
l'histoire du jeune fille
départ timide très introverti
et je leur demandais en fait je lui ai
posé pas mal de questions et elle avait
même du mal à me parler
voulait même pas elle avait du mal à me
raconter son histoire et là je me suis
rappelé de la fameuse phrase de mon père
la personnalité on maîtresses de venir
ce code tu deviendras demain dépend de
ton état d'esprit aujourd'hui
allez de la jeune fils du personnel qui
grâce à sa passion la technologie
l'informatique a réussi à transformer la
vie de jaune a réussi à pas mal de
personnes à rêver rêver rêver encore
obtention de son bac
la jeune fille est orienté dans une
filière en sciences de la vie et de la
terre elle était super passionnés et
voulait-elle bouffer la filière parce
que elle voulait embrasser la même
carrière que sa mère à mère professeur
de sciences naturelles
donc elle voulait aussi être professeur
d'université
après trois années à l'université
obtient sa licence mais malheureusement
dans le pays une ville une crise post
électorale
les universités sont fermées deux ans
et là où ils font en fait trouver une
alternative
il faut se réorienter ses parents
décident alors de lui payer des cours
d'universités privées et se renseigne
elle ne trouve pas d'universités privées
dans son pays qui proposent des coûts en
sciences naturelles et la famille lui
demande de trouver une nouvelle filière
quelque chose d'autres artères el-assad
hui la décision la plus importante parce
qu'elle avait déjà construit son plan de
carrière elle savait exactement ce
qu'elle voulait faire lui fallait
repartir de zéro
des parents décident de lavettes l'aide
de ses amis de ses tantes et oumou de
l'esprit de n'est pas d'ingénierie en
sciences informatiques des parents
décident dans l de l'inscrire dans une
école du d'informatique
parce que pour l'informatique peint sur
un métier d'avenir
donc elle aussi elle de construire un
nouveau projet professionnel
la province et cours en informatique
c'est pas tout de suite évident c'est
dur informatique c'est difficile et elle
est heurtée à la frustration de l'âge
oui la frustration de l'âge parce que l
avait déjà fait quatre années à
l'université elle est repartie de zéro
elle était d'une même classe avec des
étudiants qui rémunère fraîchement de
l'université kate devait côtoyer avec
qui elle devait travailler et s est
sentie frustrée et à chaque fois
elle avait voulu abandonner à chaque
fois et voulait baisser les bras parce
que c'était difficile parce qu'elle n'en
pouvait plus parce qu'elle passait des
nuits blanches afin du code
elle se rappelait de la fameuse phrase
la personnalité une maîtresse de venir
arrive au moment où pour tout étudiant
c'est facile des étudiants de la salle
pour tout étudiant de confronter à enfin
de notre premier stage de
perfectionnement donc être déposé son cv
un peu partout aucune réponse
personne ne l'appelle et séditieux moi
je suis inscrit dans l'une des menus et
icônes informatique et personne ne
m'appelle pour un stage elle comprend
que avant un boulot c'est comme le
royaume des cieux
seuls les violences qu'on en parle
et quelques mois plus tard une
recommandation de l'ong de ses amis de
la tente
elle obtient et stages et là elle fait
la promesse à sa mère le travail est
tellement dure
était ce un peu à la sortie de
l'obtention de son diplôme elle n'est
même pas à solliciter les entreprises et
que ce sont les entreprises qui courent
vers elle nous proposer du boulot
l'ufal est donc réalisé un exploit et
lui fallait donc être la meilleure dans
ce domaine
c'est là qu'intervient cette jeune fille
et héritière y travaillait comme fille
de ménage suis la marraine de la jeune
fille en question et séries à 16 ans
avec déjà un enfant elle est venue à la
capitale où chercher en vain de l'eau
parce que et riz était pleine de rêves
et riz voulait faire la culture
eri chercher un travail décent pour
pouvoir s'occuper de sa fille
malheureusement herry n'étaient pas amis
à l'école
eri ne savez pas lire et sarpei crir
elle savait pas calculer c'est pas dans
cette salle est est ce que là quelqu'un
qui ce palais écrit
[Musique]
vous voyez vous fait de privilégier on
est joueur on est tous de privilégier
l'argent on a nos blocs notes on lit on
est crise vous trouvez ça c'est évident
mais c'est même pas évident pour
certaines ou herry la région de laquelle
elle vénère on ne scolarise est pas le
fit malheureusement donc mairie n'avait
pas eu accès à l'éducation
et oeri avoir envie d'apprendre elle
avait un rêve où les faits la culture s
inscrivant dans le dos des cours
d'alphabétisation
malheureusement elle n'a pas pu
effectuer ses coûts parce qu'on n'avait
pas le temps elles n'avaient pas la
disponibilité pour faire ses cours
d'alphabétisation encore une autre
frustration est arrivé au moment où la
jeune fille décide avec terry donc pour
construire une application
d'alphabétisation qui allait permettre à
erie de pouvoir apprendre à lire écrire
et calculer
partout où elles se trouvent dans la
cuisine dans la salle de bain pendant un
repère en train de regarder la
télévision
eri avait la possibilité d'apprendre par
tous et ce de manière autonome elle
n'avait besoin de personne
on avait besoin de 1 avec besoin de
personne de pas de tuteur pour
l'accompagner dans son apprentissage
l'habitation d'alphabétisation a fallu à
cette je ne suis pas mal de prix à la
haye a été mêlé à développer
d'applications dans son pays elle a
remporté des prix à l'international en
local et tout ça la jeune fille venait
de réaliser un exploit
elle était meilleur dans son domaine
pour résumer c'est que j'ai appris de
cette histoire c'est que pour réaliser
pour ceux réalisés soit il faut
apprendre à réaliser les choses il faut
motiver les gens il faut accompagner les
jeux super important le rêve de herri a
permis de réaliser ses rêves
ensuite elle et elle sollicité de
partout comme la comece est venu à sa
mère pour les entreprises de la voulait
plus gros que je voulais travailler avec
elle était sollicitée et tout et décide
de créer une entreprise
elle décide ne pas travailler pour y est
défi de créer sa propre entreprise et
des sites de fait de la formation ainsi
d'entreprendre dans l'éducation mais pas
n'importe quelle formation
elle voulait pas de la magie oui la
magie parce que c'est rappeler et si
elle n'avait pas été appelé pour un
stage parce que c'est juste parce que
les compétences de que dans son cv
n'avait n'avait rien à voir n'était même
pas en adéquation avec la réalité du
terrain
elle est un jeune est sorti de l'école
avec des compétences padduc
elle n'avait pas de savoir faire
elle n'avait pas de métier et était
juste diplômés alors la jeune fille
décide de créer une école une forme à
l'apprentissage des métiers fm à
l'apprentissage de tous les métiers
techniques du numérique elle décide de
faire monter en compétences
n'importe qui et même si la personne ne
sait pas lui mais un ordinateur un 7
mois d'apprentissage
la personne aura le même savoir-faire
que pourquoi plus est quelqu'un qui a
fait cinq ans les années à l'université
elle décide de faire à kong
m me dis aux gens
jeunes ils s'appellent joshua s josien
qui m'a particulièrement inspiré parce
que il tint jeunes togolais thème jeunes
togolais qui a intégré l'école de la
jeune fille quand on dû parler de
l'école et qui a fait le déplacement en
bus jusqu'au pays de la jeune fille pour
pouvoir intégrer l'école parce que josué
était plein de rêves josy vous
l'apprendre la programmation
malheureusement je n'avais pas les
moyens il ne pouvait pas se payer une
école d'ingénieur il ne pouvait pas se
payer une école pour apprendre
l'informatique
ils étaient donc obligés de inscrits
dans l'école de la jeune fille qui
offrait la formation gratuite
l'école permet à toutes les personnes en
situation sociale difficile des
personnes ils n'ont pas accès à
l'éducation et les personnes qui veulent
se former les personnes qui sont motivés
à un prompt à vouloir toujours apprendre
et ensuite est inséré et ce gratuitement
aujourd'hui josué est l'un des meilleurs
développeurs de sa génération il
travaille de nuit une entreprise
américaine
inna que le bac
ce jeune homme qui s'appelle à claude
kouassi chastel a claqué un jeune
béninois également y est rond de sa vie
arrêté ses études
parce que c'est par n'avait plus les
moyens de se payer de lui payer la
formation et cg nord il s'est redonné un
tout petit métier il a commencé à être
chauffée de baca apprentis voire en
europe
il a vendu des lots dans les gares
routières il a tout fait il s'adonnait à
plusieurs petits métiers est ce gênant
il avait un rêve il rêvait d'intégrer
une grande entreprise qui rêvait d'être
quelqu'un avec un bon emploi
malheureusement n'avaient pas le moyen
et malheureusement ils pouvaient même
pas te payer le transport pour se rendre
d'un quelconque manque de formation des
jeunes à intégrer l'école de la jeune
fille est aujourd'hui
ateras des îles à développeurs
d'applications et travaille dans l'un
des meilleurs cabinets de développement
d'applications de son pays après sept
mois de formation n'a que le match
tout comme jésus est apte la d il y à
des millions de jeunes veulent se former
ils veulent apprendre le métier on veut
rêver malheureusement ils sont dans des
situations sociales difficiles où
certains n'arrivent pas à se payer le
transport pour d'autres n'arrivent même
pas à se payer la nourriture et la jeune
fille aujourd'hui décident de former ces
jeunes gratuitement elle a donné un
emploi en suisse
la meilleure manière de se réaliser et
d'aider les autres à surya la meilleure
manière de se réaliser et d'aider les
autres à ce mondial
et vous
or rêve de qui avez vous une fois essayé
de donner vie
robes de qui
avez vous une
hu a essayé de donner
cette jeune fille comme moi
[Applaudissements]
je me nomme barreau raïssa je suis
analyste programmeur je suis
en 2015 j'ai monté une entreprise
sociale et solidaire et propose la
formation gratuite à toutes les
personnes défavorisées à toutes les
personnes qui désirent de se former on
les forme et on les inserts je suis
directrice et monsieur l'académie by
simple au vivat trice également deux
simples en côte d'ivoire et qui a décidé
en fait il ya quelques mois de créer il
a dit qu scoop
il permet également au jeu et on de
diplôme en informatique qui n'ont pas de
savoir faire et de les former et des
données de les faire monter en
compétences et ya quelques mois j'ai
réalisé que au delà de ma timidité je
t'ai quelqu'un de de pragmatique
au delà de ma timidité j'étais quelqu'un
qui avait du talent et j'ai voulu mettre
ce talent là au service de
l'administration et depuis près de six
mois
je suis fonctionnaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous messieurs bizarrement je suis
fonctionnaire oui avec mon salaire de
180 mille merci merci à tous merci je
vous invite surtout de ce cahier de
donner vie aux rêves de triplé passant
culte nous on tour quelques choix qui
nous ont quel que soit notre domaine
d'activité nous avons la possibilité
d'aider nous avons la possibilité d'un
pape et nous avons la possibilité de
mener des actions de changements dans
les vies au rêve de toutes les personnes
qui vous entourent vous remercie
[Musique]